brach Meyer premise of the show i I
think I encapsulated it but it really is
a great idea your character has a
meltdown because he finds out that his
wife has been cheating on him and what I
love about it is that your characters
are very good play-by-play announcer and
he starts discussing how his wife
humiliated him in between accurately
calling the game yeah he never stopped
like but premise was do these guys
always sound like this and they can say
anything they want as long as they give
the count this guy I'm talking like
Brock my Ratna yeah this guy walks in on
his wife in the middle of an orgy
actually and in a blackout drunk you
know ends up saying things on the air in
the middle of the baseball broadcast
like hey for you kids watching at home a
strap-on is what mommy is used to
penetrate daddies and Johnson swings and
misses at a breaking ball Owen - you
never lose the rhythm oh no no the great
things yeah continues to call the game
until he's just reduced to a puddle on
the floor and then is thrown out of
baseball as you might imagine yeah and
and then he unit Eve's golf ends up
calling cockfights in the Philippines on
television which they really do by the
way mm-hmm it's a big deal over there I
know they have cockfights yes and they
televised um yeah which Brock mines are
doing he makes it back to the minor
leagues with Amanda Peet's team and not
enthused about this but one of the
things is very talented wordsmith and
your character has very as a lot of
announcers have to have they have great
things they say about a home run or a
line drive they have great little sort
of colorful you know euphemisms and
you're carrying what are some of the
favorite ones that you've said or do you
have a favorite one that your there's a
couple of good Brock Meyer ones
oh man that ball cannot be buried in a
Jewish cemetery because it just got
tattoos
I really like that somebody get me some
antibiotics because that ball is
gonorrhea I would listen to yeah you
should you got it you got to do that for
home well now as promoting the show I've
been getting I was in the Mets radio
booth last week and I've been doing I've
been actually starting to call games
like this is great I want to hear you do
a whole game I think that'd be really
fun
you